pressure mounting on kamala harris over
when she'll actually visit
if ever the border for a first-hand look
at the crisis she's supposed to fix
you haven't been to the border i and i
haven't been to europe
and i mean i don't i don't understand
the point that you're making
i've been to the border before i will go
again but when i'm in guatemala
dealing with root causes i think we
should have a conversation about what's
going on in guatemala
can you commit right now that you will
indeed visit the u.s mexico border and
will you do it soon
yes i will and i have before
why is she laughing uh here to react uh
pinal county arizona sheriff mark lamb
sheriff do you know why she wouldn't go
to the border
yeah look we're as we're as confused as
obviously she was after that question i
look this is our vice president who says
to lester
i don't even know what you're asking
here listen kamala if you don't know
what he's asking then
you're definitely not the right person
for the job she keeps proving time and
time again why she's not the right
person for the job
this is an important issue for her
that's why she's not coming down
and we are left to only believe that
this is exactly what they want they want
this chaos
that is coming into this country that's
why they refuse to address it and her in
particular
and it's not a laughing matter shame on
her
so you know people focus on texas it's
terrible in arizona i've talked to you
enough to know that and
you see the exasperation of the attorney
general as well as
the governor they don't seem to care is
the theory sheriff
if i see it i own it if i'm actually
seen
at the border with these uh these soft
facilities which are filled with
children
and these and the chaos of other
children being dropped over the wall
uh and the sh and the border patrol
rounding up thousands if she's seen
with this she'll actually have to own
this
yeah brian you're probably right if
she's seen with it they have to own it's
almost like a little kid where if they
just ignore it it's not a problem
um but it is a problem kamala i'm
telling you it's a problem and we all
know it and the american people know it
they're wise to it they know this and
yet they refuse to address it she
refused to come down here
you know and they keep saying that
they're addressing the root problems
down in places like guatemala
i would i would contend heavily contend
that the root cause is joe biden and
kamala harris and their policies their
fail
failed policies that's what they need to
fix first and foremost
then if you want to go down and fix the
rest of the world's problems do so but
we got plenty of our own here let's
start with those sheriff what's
what's your response when she says uh
this is a long to there's no
short-term fix this is a long-term
problem it's been around forever
every day is a five-alarm fire by for
you
and your other officers don't tell me i
gotta wait
a decade to fix it we've got a million
people here illegally
exactly but this is a it is a problem
that has existed for a long time but we
had a president over the last four years
who was working hard to fix that
president trump
was doing what he needed to do the wall
was being built we were seeing a
reduction in
illegal immigration we were seeing a
reduction in drug trafficking
although the drugs were increasing in
amounts the amount of bus we had were
reducing
or at least staying the same so these
are these are successes we were having
but now
these policies they have they're made
making it even
longer game and as long as they refuse
to to secure the border and shut it down
she's right this is never going to go
away and it's going to take forever to
fix it
and just keep in mind if you're watching
from around the country and you're not
in a border city or a border state
the problem's yours too because they are
shipping the illegals
out of these border areas and into your
town
and they're not going to tell you
they'll just be there and they might be
fine people that's just not the way a
country
can exist and thrive that's not the way
immigration system
should be working and it's not just
guatemalans got over a hundred countries
coming through the border uh from africa
to the caribbean to romania
so this is a mess and i don't think she
accomplished one
thing except for pledging more of our
money to countries that don't deserve it
uh sheriff thanks so much thank you
brian
all right you got it